[Music]
machine gun kelly's daughter might be
following in his musical footsteps i
think like the torch will pass on her
and she'll have her own she'll have her
you know this is just the start of her
amazing life
check out 13 year old casey spitting
jay-z's verse from beyonce's 2003 hit
song crazy in love
[Music]
mgk simply captions the clip parenting
[Music]
like father like daughter right that's
hard to top that one man now casey's
musical abilities should come as no
surprise last year mgk told kelly
clarkson how much he values her opinion
when it comes to his tunes i trust her
opinion more than i trust my own now
like she has her finger on the pulse of
like what's
what's hot or like if i'm doing a song
and it's the right one like she'll you
know like she'll confirm it she also has
like
does she also tell you when it's crap oh
yeah for sure because my daughter
doesn't she's seven
casey not only has a good ear she's also
a talented athlete and mgk he's one
proud volleyball dad they like came up
to me with like recruitment papers and
stuff like that i was like
whoa what is this like the nba draft
when you go to like the sporting events
are you a yeller are you that
embarrassing dad yeah i like so i i
always roll deep to the to the games and
so bring a positive yes
fans get a deeper look into the rocker's
relationship with his daughter in his
new documentary life in pink the world
was rooting against us his music sucks
he's just sell out people say that stuff
from my dad but you will only see one
side
going to a daughter's volleyball game 9
30 in the morning
and when et spoke with the musician at
the premiere he said his baby girl is
the highlight of the whole thing we see
the highs and the lows of this period in
your life which is exceptional that you
opened up to your fans in in that means
casey is such a bright young lady she is
she is she's she stole the dog to me do
you plan on watching it with her i don't
know man i don't know i don't know i
i don't know i mean
to me she's so she speaks so eloquently
and she speaks so so truthfully i loved
hearing you say that it was all about
the legacy you live in believing her you
know it's a beautiful thing because
she'll be better than i am
you know like she'll she'll
she'll learn from these things that
i'm going through and then hopefully you
know i can see it in her already she's
wait she's more she's she's going she's
better than i am and she'll be better
than i could ever be
[Music]